[inaudible]
guys.
Um,
I'm really happy to be here.
Thanks to Dave and Company for uh,
ushering me in hosting me so well,
I often ask for the slot right before lunch because then I'm all powerful.
I'm like what's between the audience and lunch?
Uh,
and it's,
it's fun to play that game,
but I think most of us had lunch.
Uh,
so I guess I'm between you and work,
so we should just linger as long as we can.
And the Q and a.
Um,
I thought I would just share a little bit about the book,
how I came to the story,
share a few passages from it and then get into a Q and a and sort of learn
what's on your mind and have a kind of back and forth.
So breaking and entering is the true story of a female hacker called alien and
the birth of our information insecurity age.
And I should make clear from the onset that alien is a white hat hacker.
She is someone who is paid by big businesses and government agencies to try to
break into them in order to see how they can be broken into.
Uh,
she also does recovery work if someone has already been breached coming in,
doing forensics,
uh,
and other kinds of analysis to figure out what happened,
how to recover and why.
And she also does a variety of other things such as digital hostage situations
and kind of ransomware cases.
For example,
where you've got 24 hours to have your hospital system or law firm or tech
company.
I get the data that has been compromised back,
uh,
and you have to pay $200,000 in Bitcoin and she kind of answers,
is that true?
Is there another way to get it out?
Uh,
if you do want to pay $200,000 in Bitcoin,
how do you do that,
uh,
in the next few hours?
How do you do that without getting triple infected on the way back?
Um,
she,
ah,
we'll,
we'll talk more about that and sorta end of my talk as I get to that end of her
career.
But I want to go back a bit.
So,
um,
I guess I want to just get a sense of the room.
Uh,
is anyone here or who here is,
I know there's a lot of different teams.
Who here is insecurity in some ways?
Okay.
So I think I got about 15 or so.
Have you.
Um,
so that means there's like 30 people insecurity and 15 are,
are,
are admitting it.
Um,
I've learned,
I've learned the math.
Um,
and I guess on the flip side,
is anyone here,
I won't make you tell the gory details.
Is anyone here,
uh,
been hacked?
Okay.
So I don't see any hands.
So as the 15 people who did raise their hand could tell you that means like 40
of you have been hacked,
I guess 10 have you have,
you know it,
you don't want to admit it.
That's okay.
And you know,
we can multiply that by four.
So then,
you know,
that's another 40 of you have.
And I guess just don't know it yet.
Um,
has anyone ever been targeted,
uh,
by a hacker?
Have you ever like gotten an email that might not have been from the person who
said it was,
there might've been a link if you clicked on it and it was a bad idea and he
made you all carry some special device from now on to do anything at work
anyway.
Uh,
yeah.
Has anyone ever got a,
I got a call on Monday from the help desk,
have you ever,
right.
Um,
or it can be face to face and we'll talk about some circumstances like that too.
So that is basically all of us are targeted every day,
all the time.
And so we're in an interesting situation where hacking is now a field where
everyone,
not just at Google,
but it's pretty well aware of it,
um,
from little kids to great grandmothers and all of us are targeted.
And we know that hackers have an outsized influence on parts of our economy,
on our politics,
uh,
on our culture.
But we'd still,
for the most part,
if you ask people what does a hacker look like,
they don't have a face.
So,
uh,
maybe they pop up a popular search engine.
Uh,
if you do an image search,
uh,
for hacker,
Gosh,
you get literally no faces.
I,
you get shadowed figures and hoodies or occasional guy Fawkes masks.
But don't worry,
you know,
I'm sure the fourth search result,
no,
the fifth,
the 20th,
the 400th,
um,
it just goes on and on.
Uh,
there are no faces,
uh,
to this field,
even though it is so integral to,
you know,
we're all thinking about it more and more often to newspaper every day.
So as a writer,
that's an incredible opportunity,
right?
Can I tell the story?
Can I show the face?
Can I show the field growing up?
Uh,
you wouldn't necessarily know it by the cover of my book.
It's not that different.
But you know,
I'm wedded to the world that your search engine results have created.
And so if I want to signal that it's a book about a hacker,
I've got to have a shadowy figure,
um,
with ones and Zeros.
But inside I try to put a face on the top.
So how did I come to the story?
How did I get this chance to kind of follow,
um,
hacking over the last 20 years?
Because if you think about it,
even when we have a face,
that face is like 30,
40 years old at this point,
it's like Matthew Broderick in war games,
uh,
or Angelina Jolie and hackers.
Um,
so it's an incredible opportunity.
So did I just start following people with hoodies,
uh,
down alleyways until I found someone going into the dark web,
before the Sanford,
whatever the FBI could,
could trap them in a San Francisco public library.
Um,
I didn't,
I found this story through an alternate investigative journalism.
Nothing.
I picked my daughter up from preschool,
so I went to pick her off and there was a new classmate they were playing
together with the girls ran off to the playground.
If you ever have like five year olds,
you know that the best babysitter for a five year old is a five a,
they kind of cancel each other out and they,
they occupy each other.
It's like mutually assured something.
Ah,
so I'm talking to the mom and she says,
Hey,
you know what,
what do you do?
And I think that this is going to be great.
I'm going to be the interesting person in this conversation.
I'm a writer.
I write these books,
I write these articles and I talk about myself for 10 minutes.
Um,
and to be polite,
I say,
uh,
you know,
what about you?
What do you do?
And she says,
well,
tomorrow I have to break into a bank.
And I realized,
Oh,
I'm not the interesting person in this conversation.
And that led to a longer series of conversations and I found out,
yeah,
there's this one whole field that's a real,
uh,
and this whole profession that's grown up over the last 20 years as I described
to you at the beginning of people who are,
have the same skills as the bad guys and do the same activities in a high end,
professional,
organized way.
But do it under contract.
You pay them big bucks for the privilege of having them try to break into you
and hopefully you get them to do it before,
uh,
you've been broken into already by a more malicious actor.
So as I follow her story and heard more about it,
I got really excited because even in the field of hacking,
people tend to specialize.
You get car hacker's,
you get elevator hackers,
you get people working in a particular operating system or mobile phone
operating system or particular network vulnerability.
Um,
but alien had gone through a huge variety of worlds and her career,
if you will,
it didn't start as a,
it started as a sort of fun activity,
um,
had grown up at the same time this profession had.
So in following her story,
I could follow hackings growth from this sort of skateboarding like subculture
to what's now,
I think $140 billion cybersecurity industry and not just a large and valuable
industry,
but one that touches every aspect of our lives and gives us insight every aspect
of our life.
So the hope was if I can follow a hacker in her footsteps,
a readers can do the same and you don't,
it's not just what you know,
reading about it,
uh,
or learning about it.
It's also you'll experience it yourself and kind of understand our
vulnerabilities or our capabilities in a new way.
So I want to share a few passages to illustrate some of the breadth of her
world.
Uh,
one I won't share just for time reasons is the beginning.
she started as a 17 year old at MIT.
Do we have any MIT grads here?
You got at least one?
Uh,
two?
Yeah.
Anyone do a course 19.
I got to smile and I got a puzzled look.
So at MIT majors are called courses.
So what,
what was,
what was the name of your number?
What was the,
what was your course?
Of course 18,
which is what of course,
18 math.
What was your course?
Of course six.
Three,
which was computer science.
Okay.
So they're numbered and they go up to like 24.
19 is not an assigned number.
There is no designated course.
19 but unofficially,
of course,
19 is hacking and hacking at MIT predates computers.
It does not directly refer to computers at all.
It refers to physical exploration.
So I was familiar with part of this tradition.
There's this tradition of elaborate in genius physical pranks,
like getting a police car on top of the Dome at Mit,
uh,
or having a complete living room set couch,
you know,
um,
liquor cabinet,
even a cat,
a newspaper,
a upside down,
uh,
on the,
arch outside the media lab at MIT or working tetris game that's playable on the
windows of the tallest building on campus.
And I was familiar with these hacks,
but it wasn't,
I didn't think about the foundational skills needed to do that.
You don't just kind of get up at,
you know,
noon or eight or nine at night and said to your buddies,
hey,
we should put a police car on the dome.
Maybe you do that,
but you're not going to pull it off.
You've got to be able to pick locks,
sneak past security guards,
climb on ledges,
disassemble and assemble a car.
You've got to be able to do that in the dark.
You've got to be able to do that with a small group of people.
You can really trust to keep a secret and you've got to be able to get in and
out.
Uh,
and the same thing with the tetris game.
The same thing with the living room set.
The same thing with all these other hacks and there is pulling up a hack is the
what I just described,
but going happiness,
totally different.
You're exploring,
uh,
for the sake of exploring.
You're going through steam tunnels,
you're going along ledges,
you're climbing up elevator shafts,
you're finding hidden or unused spaces inside of the buildings that everyone
else takes for granted and sort of goes through as a,
a normal civilian.
And that's exciting.
It's perilous.
Um,
and it has this direct analog to computer hacking.
You know,
where you're also getting into forbidden spaces.
You're also,
um,
working off label with what somebody else has created.
If an inventor creates something new and an engineer builds to Spec a Hector
creates something new with something someone else has built to Spec.
Um,
so you're often knowing spaces in a way that the creator themselves didn't.
And that's a direct analog to computer hacking.
We know today she goes from that world into computer security as it's becoming a
new field.
And I thought I'd read a short passage from a section where she is working in
information security.
It's about 2005 in a hospital system,
one of the largest hospitals in the country.
We're aware,
especially now,
uh,
that everything that is a computer can be hacked and that everything is a
computer,
but it still is different to know that,
uh,
and to experience it firsthand.
So for example,
in a hospital you're connected on average when you're in a hospital bed to about
11 different medical devices,
those Evan Network card,
usually those have an operating system.
It's usually built on windows,
uh,
maybe a little more units in the past.
Hey,
maybe a chrome or uh,
you know stuff right now.
And that means it's going to have the same vulnerabilities that those systems
have.
Hospital equipment is also often bought on a 15 to 20 year time cycle because
it's millions of dollars.
And so that means when you go to the hospital in 2019,
you may be experiencing a systems that are serving you,
that have the vulnerabilities of 2004 or 1999.
Uh,
but don't worry,
we will have the security we have today,
uh,
in just 15 to 20 years.
Uh,
so your grandchildren will have the secure systems.
so looking at trying to protect that and what that looks like was really
interesting and trying to recreate that through her experiences going on site,
talking to her old bosses and colleagues.
And I thought I'd share a bit from that.
So what happens is,
um,
she gets a call from the network team at the hospital and they're having a
bandwidth issue.
Something is a clogging the network.
And so devices aren't able to communicate and some of them are shutting off.
And that's a crisis in a situation where the flow of data is literally matter of
life and death.
And people need to be able to contact each other across wards,
transfer information.
And the devices themselves are lifesaving.
She goes to the office of her colleague,
Amy,
on the network team.
Amy was a Linkee Brunette,
27 or 28 dressed in jeans and a teal pullover.
Alien Knelt beside her inner cubicle as they studied network traffic information
from Internet addresses across the hospital.
We started getting calls two or three hours ago saying the Internet was slow.
Amy told her I checked it out and they're right.
Some internal address is just spewing traffic.
It's gotta be a worm.
Alien said,
can you shut off the port?
I could,
but I don't know what's plugged into it.
Amy said,
what if it's an important machine?
I don't want to just cut it off.
Let me see.
Alien said she stepped up to the keyboard and scrolled back through Amy's
command history,
double checking her investigation.
Amy was a pro though on the basis of the Internet address alone.
The closest they could do was trace the worms origin point to a third floor
hallway in the same building that held the Er aliens.
Eyes narrowed.
Stay here,
I'll find it.
She said alien ran the elevator,
popped outside and cut diagonally across the campus.
Seven minutes later,
wide sliding doors separated for her at the entrance to the Er,
Amy had called ahead for backup and it staff are assigned to this building.
Met Alien at the third floor hallway and showed her to the right network switch.
It serviced a long quiet hallway.
By now.
Alien had burned almost half an hour,
but she was getting closer back out on the hallway.
Alien stopped in front of the only door in sight.
Doctors and nurses swished past alien stepped back feeling out of place without
a white coat or scrubs.
When a nurse slowed before the door,
however alien flagged her down.
Hi,
I'm from it.
Security,
she said,
and showed her badge.
I need to get in here.
Oh,
the nurse swiped her own badge and the door clicked open.
I'll have to accompany you.
She's warned.
This is a restricted area.
The room was warm and dark and we could make out a few rows of what appeared to
be high narrow carts on wheels,
each with a monitor nearby.
It was vaguely reminiscent of a server room,
but her entire concern was with the network ports located close to the floor.
Alien dropped to a crawl using the same mag lights you'd had since her freshman
year at Mit.
She swept the walls looking for the guilty court.
20 seconds past 40 60 finally,
aliens beam illuminated a yellow plastic port cover to which someone with a
label maker had attached the Alpha numeric name of the infected machine.
Alien smiled and triumph and relief.
She used the MAG light to trace the black ethernet cord coming out of the port.
It led to a profusion of other plugs and cables entering the back of the machine
closest to her she'd page Amy and Amy would alert their bosses.
They'd get the problem diagnosed as soon as possible before the machine is
infected.
Anything further,
alien stood up.
She gave up the nurse touching her back gently to get her attention without
speaking.
Turn that flashlight off please.
She asked,
and a low,
but from whisper it was more a command than a request.
Alien obeyed.
She felt a sense of alarm,
even dread,
and she'd done something wrong.
We're worthy.
There weren't any patients in this room.
She had thought it had no beds,
only more machines like this one per census suddenly heightened.
However,
she now heard the sound of slow breathing all around her for the first time
since their eyes became accustomed to the dark alien.
Took a look around the room on each of the wheeled stands was a teeny palette
enclosed by clear plastic.
The Palette she saw now held teeny blankets and under each blanket was a baby,
a teeny one sprawled out on its back and head turned to one side.
All wired up.
These newborns were essentially on life support and fast asleep.
The room might resemble a server room alien realized,
but it wasn't.
It was the Nicu,
the neonatal intensive care unit,
babies she said to herself.
So experiences like that or eye opening because you realize,
uh,
you know,
the virus,
the worm,
the other vulnerability can be a life support system.
Uh,
for,
you know,
a cluster of kids that's not a port you want to pull,
uh,
right away from her work in security.
She moves to kind of the other side of the fence.
And this was fun for me because it was the intersection of these two worlds,
this physical breaking and entering she had done as an undergraduate and the
computer security work.
She gets hired as a penetration tester or a pen tester,
uh,
testing security,
at fortune 500 companies,
government agencies around the country and around the world.
And I thought I'd share a short passage from,
uh,
her first day at work.
We can all just think about what our first day of work was or our first day of
work at this campus.
Uh,
kind of onboarding process.
What was the first task you had to do?
The kind of nervousness there.
And then think about this as your first day of work in a,
in a sort of new opportunity.
Ted Roberts,
castle banks,
head of security,
requested a private booth at the hotel restaurant,
a friendly blonde 40 year old man in a business suit.
He leaned across the table after dinner and pass both Richard and alien his
business card and assigned one page note alien skim the document which she had
written and sent to Ted asking him to fill in the blanks and bring it to their
meeting tonight.
Castle Bank has hired a lead defense to perform physical security penetration
tests and assessments of nine sites in three states.
It said specific addresses followed starting here with the banks or regional
headquarters and four branches.
She and Richard had driven by today doing local reconnaissance for the rest of
the week.
Ted's note authorized.
They were to probe the facilities one by one to determine if an uninvited
visitor could enter,
explore,
remove equipment or data or rob the banks.
The letter closed with instructions on how to contact Ted if they got caught
your get out of jail.
Free letter.
He said Richard Herano but alien gave her best smile folding the letter in
policing at inner coat pocket.
Thanks.
She said patting the pocket afterward.
I hope we won't need it.
Ted Signal to a waiter for the check.
Good luck,
but not too much luck.
He said
Tuesday,
noon,
the clock told an office workers exited the 20 story headquarters.
Everyone was bundled up and breathing out steam on their way to lunch,
moving in the opposite direction.
Richard entered the lobby to check it out and we can watch from the front
passenger seat of the car clutching an empty black laptop case.
No,
not completely empty while she waited,
alien reached her fingers into the zippered pocket and checked there.
They were beside her get out of jail.
Free letter,
fake business cards she'd printed after dinner with Ted last night.
Elizabeth Testament enterprise technology specialist.
They said right of the Red Castle Bank logo above her real cell phone number of
fake castle corporate email address and the address of this building.
Each element copied from Ted's business card and only inside shifting
impatiently.
Then she sat up quickly seeing Richard approached the car.
Did you get in alien asked after he had taken his seat and shut the door.
Richard responded scornfully there's no way he reported.
What do you mean?
She said I'll leave done was try the lobby.
What about the freight elevator or the storage room of the open window?
What happened?
Forget it.
Richard turned up the heat or and made to shift the car into drive.
It's freezing.
He said,
let's move.
We can totally do this.
Alien unbuckled her seatbelt met me try and she said,
Richard shook his head.
You won't get in.
He insisted there are turnstiles in a security guard watching everything.
It'll just blow our cover.
He continued gruffly.
Let's try the bank branches first.
If there's time,
we'll come back here.
We found plenty already.
We're here now,
said alien and I won't blow our cover.
Richard could spot a narrow opening an offense and 50 yards and recite security
cameras aspects from memory,
forthright,
credible and confident.
He was like all of her bosses.
Terrific.
At presentations.
It was clear,
however that he had neither the patients nor the aptitude for with those in the
infosec community called social engineering.
Bluntly put the term at manipulating people.
You might call it charming them or in some cases scaring them,
but it was always about getting them to do what you wanted.
Whoever you were.
The trick was to assess the other person and figure out how to,
you might talk him or her into something,
perhaps the best name for it.
It might be human hacking.
Freshman year,
for example,
getting Alex and Vlad to help alien with her calculus homework had been social
engineering.
More recently she had turned her dinner out with the bosses into a kind of job
interview.
Consciously or not every child or parent teacher or military leader,
politician or player on the dating scene,
you social engineering for pen testers or their criminal counterparts like those
who send phishing emails or persuaded victims to empty their bank accounts.
The appeal was obvious.
Why bother breaking into anything when you can get individuals to open their
doors for you and because people,
especially men,
were generally less suspicious of women in this kind of situation being female,
it could be an advantage.
It will be fine.
Alien smiled sweetly.
I'll be quick and come right back.
If there's any problem before Richard could say another word.
She was out the door with her laptop case alien cross,
the gray slate floor of the spacious lobby for hip high stainless steel gateways
stood between her and the elevators.
Each was equipped with a wedge shaped black barrier that receded when you placed
your badge on a scanner.
Then as soon as anyone past the gateway,
the barrier closed immediately preventing tailgating next to the gates was a
wide marble counter.
Also gray behind which stood a white haired guard in a crisp black uniform
including a matching tie.
She walked toward the badge reader system as though expecting to go through when
the barriers stopped.
Her alien acted startled purposely trying to catch the guards.
I then she approached him,
hi.
She said,
I'm with it.
We have a computer emergency on the seventh floor.
I need to get up there.
She would be happy to get an anywhere but new from remote reconnaissance that
this was the floor with the most day to day office up close.
The man looked even older than she had originally estimated at least 65 iLien
guest with thin gold frame,
bifocals and permanent greases in his forehead.
Still.
He looked in excellent shape or racked and alert.
You have to use your badge.
The guard said or I in the list.
He asked pointing to a black part cover binder on the table.
No,
I mean it.
Alien told him reassuming an old role.
I'm new.
I just started yesterday.
The guard frowned.
Where's your badge?
He asked.
I don't have a badge yet.
Set alien smoothly,
but my name is Elizabeth Testament and my boss is ted.
Robert,
Here's his card.
She lifted her laptop case in place.
It squarely on the counter between them.
She tugged the Zipper and took out and slid him one of her new cards as well as
Ted's.
The guard entered both names in his computer system.
He's in here.
He acknowledged you need to call them to get added to the list.
I mean opened her phone pretending to call Ted and leave a message as she did so
holding the phone against your ear with her shoulders.
She undid the buttons of retrenched code.
Hi,
Mr. Roberts.
She said,
this is Elizabeth.
I'm leaving you a voicemail.
I'm really sorry to bother you.
They won't let me up to the seventh floor.
I know it's an emergency.
Can you call me back please?
I'm really sorry.
Thanks.
She stood awkwardly in front of the desk checking her phone and looking
fleeting.
Lead the elevators.
The guard cringed.
I can try him again.
She said to him,
I'm really sorry to keep you waiting.
I know there was a big server crash right before I left.
He might be in the data center.
I just can't leave without fixing this.
I promised the guard was clearly conflicted.
He looked down giving her a card.
Only a second glance.
Then though he waved her forward.
Look,
I know it's important.
He said,
I'll make an exception.
Just be quick.
Thanks.
I will.
She told him just as she had Richard and leave,
grabbed her laptop bag and step forward to the closest gateway.
The guard pushed a button under the counter.
The barriers parted with a wash.
Alien was surprised to feel her heart pounding as she stepped out of the
elevator.
She'd taken much greater physical risks in college,
but she never tried to steal something.
For now at least there was nobody else on this floor.
Alien moved quickly.
Most workspaces she saw Rick cubicles containing white desks separated by six
foot freestanding gray walls at the perimeter of the four were the larger
individual offices of middle level managers with glass walls and doors.
Occupants of the cubicles personalize their space with photos and trinkets on
every desk was a black phone and a Dell laptop connected to an external keyboard
and monitor alien have did a few laptops.
All were secured with cables.
She to try the manager's spaces starting with a corner office with an unimpeded
view of the downtown.
It had the same computer set up.
The one a larger grade desk.
She lifted the laptop,
no cable alien heard the elevator ding announcing the return of the first of the
employees from lunch to men chatted as they went to their desks,
not noticing her.
She slipped out of the corner office with a laptop and walked past two more
employees and Liam was positive.
She looked as guilty as she felt that these employees ignored her to her heart
was beating harder than ever to a bank.
Nothing meant more than its reputation for trustworthiness.
The machine might have confidential customer files on it.
Castle business plans,
corporate personnel records are all of the above and identity theft ring
exploiting that information could make millions so could shady stock market
traders or any of castle's national and international competitors and the fines
and settlement fees once a big breach was disclosed,
could run to eight figures.
Choice point,
the commercial data broker had paid $15 million the previous year for giving up
information on 163,000 people.
Alien walked to the elevator as confidently as she could smiling professionally
at others as their paths crossed.
Everyone else wore a rigid badge,
but their name headshot in the castle logo clipped to their shirt or waistband.
So she shielded those areas with the laptop case.
The elevator opened back in the lobby.
Did you get it taken care of?
The security guard asked?
Yes.
Thanks so much.
Said alien giving them a thumbs up.
She crossed the street,
open the car door and slipped back inside the tourists.
Not uh,
Richard said in a,
told you so tone.
I did it,
you know,
he and said she's at to open the case.
I got a laptop.
What?
Richard's eyebrows rose as he be held her prize.
Holy Shit.
He said.
So they call that a m and m security.
It's hard on the outside,
soft in the middle and once you get past the outer defenses,
there's a lot of a good step to take.
I talked to uh,
a penetration tester who was one of her colleagues for awhile.
Do you want to guess what his specialty was?
Social engineering is the way in,
but then what does he,
what does he specialize it?
Shred bins.
He's like shred bins or the greatest,
they take all of their most confidential information.
They put it in one place and then they put it on wheels.
I was like,
nobody ever caught you?
He said,
well,
you know,
once I was willing,
one,
I'm in,
the guard stopped me and I froze.
And he said,
Hey,
what are you doing?
And I just raised my hands and he said,
that goes down in the freight elevator.
Uh,
so,
um,
definitely made me a little differently,
a tread days and my bank,
ah,
things like that.
So you start looking at things differently.
Hanging out with these hackers.
Anyway,
Rob Laptop from corporate headquarters on day one,
you get promoted pretty quickly.
If that's true.
New Job,
she's soon talking your way into bank vaults themselves and doing computer stuff
from like Internet cafes,
getting into an airline reservation system,
doing recovery for breached government.
You know,
taking a sort of antenna on the highway outside of a major defense manufacturer
and you know,
sort of whisper is sucking their data on to her computer,
uh,
and so on and so forth.
Eventually she starts her own company and sort of not on purpose so much,
but as this industry grows up and becomes a bigger and bigger field,
takes on new employees and becomes a manager and then a CEO and she has this
sort of new generation of hackers,
uh,
that she sort of trained and brought up under her wing.
And that leads to different pressures and different sort of perspective like
when you give birth and you have to debug a phishing site the same day from the
hospital.
Uh,
so that was again,
sort of parts of hackers storytelling I hadn't seen before.
I thought I'd just,
and the reading part with a couple of real short passages,
uh,
from closer to the end,
from her kind of CEO days,
Alien Path,
sorry,
Luke,
Gus,
Cheryl and two new pen testers gathered around the break table discussing their
latest work with client zero six,
six,
six avast vast retail chain,
the needed remote and onsite penetration tests,
mobile and web APP assessments,
and a security review of its credit card processing systems,
who's onsite now asked Alien Milo.
Gus answered.
He cracked their wireless network from a cafe inside one of their stores and
then wormed his way into the company's central systems.
He got root on the badge printing system,
said Cheryl,
he could add his name and photograph to the badge system and give them some
access to any building,
any room,
you name it.
One of the new pen testers piped up.
We found this internal database that had the entire shopping history of every
single customer.
Every customer asked alien.
She shopped at six six,
six.
Everybody did.
Gus Hemmed,
Cheryl tittered.
What said alien?
We found you.
Sheryl said the earliest entry was from 1993 ancient history to the 24 year old.
Congratulations.
Alien opened the fridge and grabbed a water bottle.
She pictured the entire break room papered with her life story as told through
six six six receipts for my first bra to her daughter's crib.
Last one
in mid September.
Tree Line Bank called T.
S.
C the pseudonym I use for her hacking company on behalf of one of its customers,
a construction company based in Salt Lake City.
A day earlier,
the company's payroll manager had clicked on a phishing email link that infected
his web browser with a man in the middle attack allowing hackers to see
everything he typed and even replaces familiar treeline online banking page with
an exact replica asking for additional credentials.
Only a second layer of security requiring special executive approval for large
wire transfers had stopped the firm from losing almost $60,000 to an offshore
account.
Could TSC investigate and find out what happened and how to fix it?
Susanna,
that's her COO,
sent Luke onsite to image any effected computers and interview staff.
When he returned my low,
took over using the equipment in the forensics lab to inspect everything
carefully.
That payroll manager had clicked on 19 links and as many different phishing
emails he discovered alien volunteered to help finish the job.
I'll do the malware analysis.
She said to understand how the malware worked.
Alien set it up in a sandbox recorded cordoned off virtual machine environment.
This gave her the digital equivalent of a high level biosafety lab where the
software could be safely stored,
inspected,
and dissected.
Alien started by viewing the page source for the email link that led to the man
in the middle attack.
It was neatly written by sophisticated programmers.
These bad guys or good of late,
the best black hats had emulated successful Silicon Valley entrepreneurs
licensing the use of their work through cloud based commercial software suites
called exploit kits to begin a mass attack.
You didn't have to know how to write a computer program or even have your own
computer.
You just logged in from anywhere,
shows the kind of hacks that you wanted and paid by the day,
month or year.
Some black had services accepted.
Payment by does stuck by deducting a percentage of the take.
Alien infected the virtual machine and then came back 48 hours later to check
with a digital feeds.
Had been doing the software began by configuring itself to run and startup.
Then it phoned home once every 20 minutes seeking updates or further
instructions for one of a series of modern and command and control servers
around the world.
What do you want me to do?
The program asked in essence,
and the criminals at the other end of the connection could order whatever they
wanted.
It's impressive.
She told Susanna afterward and more than a little frightening,
not just in itself,
but for what it portended.
This wasn't a solo hidden run operator.
It was the work of a group of professional hackers just like t s c cause she had
gone from novice to student,
student to practitioner,
practitioner to teacher,
and managed to manager all as a white hat hacker.
Black hat hackers across the globe had followed a parallel path,
organizing their operations,
establishing reputations and finding clients and bringing in money to their
communities.
Alien had never realized it and she had never wished for it for one could even
say she had needed the black hats to keep growing and getting new opportunities
for cell.
How many employees do you think they have?
Alien asked,
I don't know.
Susanna said,
but their sales team is definitely bigger than ours.
Alien laughed from Susanna's desk.
She picked up a little statue she had given her.
I wonder maybe on the other side of the world,
if there's an evil Susanna,
Susanna raised an eyebrow Riley,
well then they would have to be an evil alien too.
Thank you guys.
[inaudible]
so that's a kind of a taste of some of the scope and the stories and the kind of
evolution in the field and in her life trying to use the storytelling style to
kind of express that.
Um,
I'd love to,
uh,
answer any questions you have about either the writing process or other stories
from the book or other topics that are of interest to you or,
uh,
teach me something that's keeping you up at night today.
Uh,
security folks or any other folks.
and I'll pass it on to the next time.
Um,
comment on what's unique or different or interesting in particular
about her experiences as,
as a woman in this field.
So yeah,
I mean she gets that job breaking into banks by taking a security class and the
instructor there is one of the leaders of,
you know,
a major pen testing operation.
And when she goes into that class,
it is herself and there are 19 guys.
And so that's a very different experience.
And people when they start the contest at the end of that class,
which is sort of a hacking contest,
uh,
the guy's kind of shoved her aside and she and that situation at the beginning
shoves herself aside or at least lets them take the lead.
She's used to being outnumbered and she's used to being at MIT where as she put
it,
you know,
guys were taking apart hello building helicopters with their dad when they were
four and everyone was like 15
years ahead of me when I was a freshman.
So she doesn't think of herself as more technically adept.
But what she finds is her chops had been built up over the time she had a boss
between those two things at Los Alamos National Laboratory who would not let her
work to start working for him until she can do everything without her hands ever
leaving the keyboard.
And so she knew how to code.
She knew,
you know,
command line,
but she didn't know how to,
you know,
play a keyboard like a guitar,
it wasn't,
and that level of extension where you,
the computers basically an extension of your body.
She was watching her classmates who kind of nudge her aside at that contest,
sort of stumble.
They kind of wanted a graphical user interface.
They just weren't quite as adept.
They didn't have the experience she had had at the hospital.
And so eventually she sorted starts doing it on her own and little by little the
guys started lining up behind her.
Um,
and her fingers are flying and she's owning system after system.
And for her that was a transformational moment.
Not because that was when she got the skills,
but that's when she realized that she had had the skills.
Um,
cause you have that sort of image of yourself as a freshmen or a kid.
Often that's based in an insecure moment.
And then here's the moment of realizing I can do this.
And you know,
that sort of sexism or exclusion or at least being a minority continues in a lot
of different parts of her career.
Um,
but you know,
she asked to in conversations,
she says the default when she finally does get a job interview after that,
the default is if a guy's talking to the other guys assume that he knows what
he's talking about until he proves otherwise they assume the opposite in her
situation.
So she's like,
I have to sort of drop more technical references early on to sort of establish
my chops.
Um,
you know,
at least for a time she had a,
well,
yeah.
Anyway,
like you know,
it's important to talk about emacs earlier in the conversation.
Uh,
when you're a female hacker,
I'm told.
So,
um,
you know,
at the same time,
as I said,
there are fields even within hacking,
particularly where you're playing with people's expectations where that can be
an advantage.
Sometimes you want to be the innocent figure that they don't suspect is going to
be an adversary.
Other times she got like a $2 clipboard and she was the authority figure.
You put on a suit and $2 clipboard and certainly you start questioning people
and they kind of like,
let me see your,
you know,
you go to the guard,
you're like,
I'm doing a spot check.
Can I see your badge?
Can you show me?
I want to check this,
the locks on this whole building ad sooner in the bank vault so you can flip
roles too.
Um,
so,
and then there's experiences that obviously there's no escaping their gendered,
like giving birth,
being pregnant.
Uh,
these are experiences only a woman can have it at this point in our
technological life at least.
Um,
and you know,
doing that while being a CEO while being a hacker is to me another extension of
her Badassery,
uh,
and women's bad ass hurry if you will.
So,
um,
it was cool to see that,
uh,
evolution and also sort of mentoring women and men.
You know,
there are some,
some differences,
but that's in the book.
Yeah.
Are you able to say what year is she?
Uh,
1998 to 2003 yeah.
Did I assume any personal habits that I changed in the course of writing this
book?
So kind of two categories.
One,
I started doing crazy stuff because I was hanging out with hackers and trying to
report and understand their experience.
So I dunno how many of you have gone to like def con or any of the black hat,
those kinds of conventions?
Yeah.
So as you know,
there's like 25,000 actors in Vegas for the weekend and you just kind of see
where the spirit takes you in those things.
And I ended up in a shooting range that they had set up a like 30 minutes out
and the unincorporated land in the Vegas desert and there's like drone driven
skeet people are firing cannons.
They made themselves,
ah,
I was like,
well,
you know,
I've come a long way from home.
I also climbed up on the domes and MIT and alleges and did that kind of stuff.
And I got a tour through Los Alamos National Laboratory,
which is crazy,
right?
It's like you're walking through the Grand Canyon.
You take a right and there's MIT guarded by people with machine guns.
So,
um,
you know,
those were exciting.
And as for my own personal habits,
sure I started using email encryption,
I started using full disk encryption.
Um,
I was honestly more careful what I googled cause I was like somebody knowing
what I'm piping in one way or another.
Uh,
and I have certain,
you know,
agreements of confidentiality to change identifying details,
but you know,
you guys are going to know or you know,
your machines are going to know whatever I type in.
Uh,
and I left my phone,
uh,
you know,
when I took walks,
if I didn't need it,
why be tracked?
Uh,
you have a story like that where the retailer has the shopping history.
We've all,
I'm just going to make a guest.
90% of us have shopped at six,
you know,
should I,
six,
six.
Uh,
and you know,
you realize that's not an isolated thing.
We've,
we all shop period.
And everywhere we go that stuff is stored.
It's stored.
Data is forever.
So,
you know,
that kind of made me think about situations where I wanted to pay cash,
not necessarily out of paranoia,
but just out of intentionality,
if you will.
Um,
and sort of thinking about the price of convenience and certain obliviousness
and certainly things like smart fridges and doorbells are pretty terrifying to
me after hanging out,
you know,
Internet of things village,
uh,
at def con for [inaudible].
Well,
thank you very much for coming.
You are welcome.
So that's our time.
Is that what you're saying?
Yeah.
So I wanted to say,
I don't know if I've lost my,
my slides.
We may have,
I may have a gun without them too long.
Say that again.
Oh,
there you go.
Okay.
Um,
I think,
let's see.
I wanted to show you guys one more thing.
Um,
just as a sort of example of the form,
uh,
I don't know if any of you guys know a hacker named deviant,
in the Seattle community.
He's a great organizer with tool,
the open organization of lock pickers.
And he was a source,
uh,
for an,
a guide for some of this material.
And he designed a hacker bookmark,
uh,
for me and for the book.
Uh,
so it's,
uh,
it's a little bit different material than normal.
Look,
mark,
it's a kind of a flexible plastic on the back.
You can see this bookmark opens doors and it's got instructions on how to use it
for,
you know,
certain kinds of lock picking your physical entry a lot like alien and her
classmates did at Mit.
Uh,
we've got a few of these signed by me and by alien for those,
if anyone's interested,
if you get a more than one copy of the book,
uh,
then that's a kind of bonus item.
So,
uh,
think about that while supplies last.
Um,
and I'll even if there go play with play with one too,
it just to kind of get a sense of it.
Um,
there's youtube videos of him using it to get all sorts of places.
so yeah,
happy to talk more one on one.
Thank you so much for your time and um,
keep us safe and safer.
[inaudible].